[Music]
[Music]
somebody's yeah
[Music]
that's how we did it in the 90s son
i can't catch my breath man really
should i try mouth stuff what is this a
tinder date get off of me oh [ __ ]
mr dante i need an ambulance at the
quick stop
saved my life man i wish i had a life
worth saving what are you talking about
sit around and watch the same movies
over and over i always thought you could
have made a cool movie you're right i'm
living on borrowed time no more watching
movies i'm gonna make a movie
what's the movie gonna be about it's
about him working here meta everything
in the script is something either me or
someone i know said i'm not even
supposed to be here today maybe jane's
silent bob could be characters playing
silent barbara liked c-3po and r2d2
they've been here since the first movie
which was the last time they were cool
but they've been with the franchise so
long they still give them cameos and put
them on the lunch boxes sniffy
they believe in you
you put in that stuff you say about the
death star contractors
get sued by disney no way
take off your pants
uh what the hell is this i added a scene
where you get shot i'm not letting you
kill me off in the third act what if
there's a sequel a sequel what am i a
hack
i think it needs more weed
[Music]
you